[Music]
let's go to elaine in pittsburgh hey
what's up elaine
hey dr john how are you remarkable how
are you
good i am now a subscriber to your
newsletter yes
guess who's not james and kelly
i am now i beat him oh you are now james
i told you i literally did it when we
were talking about it have you already
hit unsubscribe
it's probably getting filtered through
spam it is dude hey you just made my day
elaine i am not subscribed but i'm going
to be by the end of today so you beat me
to my own newsletter we're going to make
it really big things
all right so let's take your
expectations and dial them back about
forty percent but we're going to get
there okay we're gonna get there
um thank you so much hey so what's up
how can i help
well i'm calling today because i
have a husband who i feel is a bit of a
hypochondriac uh-oh so i was just
looking for some insight into how i can
better meet his needs because i feel
that every reaction i have to him ends
in a very negative way
so why do you think he's a hypochondriac
what does that mean to you
so
he well i didn't notice anything while
we were dating or engaged probably
infatuated with him still you know and
then after how long have you been
married
seven years
oh yeah all right
see
so after some you know i noticed while
we were married i'm like oh he complains
of headaches a lot you know a couple
days a week he's complaining of
headaches
and then i would say within the past six
months to a year it's really gotten to
the point where he was convinced he had
lyme's disease he's going to his pcp
requesting blood work
he um
he's been to a cardiologist within the
past year complaining of chest pain he's
like racking up medical bills
at this point and he went to a
podiatrist for foot pain he went to a uh
and his ear hurt so he was going to an
ear nose and throat doctor and then it
just sort of got to the point where
about a week or two ago he
we're like laying in bed and he looks at
me and he is i i think i have a brain
tumor and i just
was like what what how you know what
so i said to him look me in the eye and
tell me that you you honestly think that
you have a brain tumor so he did and he
was very serious and then of course it
escalated into
you don't believe me and how can you not
love me i'm dying and you don't even
care exactly yes
you nailed it yes and i it's not true
it's you know i love him so much and i
just want to give him what he needs and
i just cannot figure out
what exactly he
wants i feel like at this point he
almost wants to be sick looking for
something
and i just don't understand what he's
looking for and i just i just really
want to help him i'm not sure how oh man
so this is beyond so um when you first
said he's a hypochondriac
i i thought it was a this is you know uh
generalization but
um my wife reminds me often that she had
children and so
i she knows i have a headache but i need
to get up and fill in the blank right or
exactly how i feel on one hand i feel i
i want to help him i want to meet
whatever needs he has i can't figure out
what that is but on the other hand i'm
like chop chop buddy we got you guys
you know
i got a brain tumor well great into the
dishwasher we'll talk about it later
excellent right exactly so has there
been any sort of finding at all
from any of these doctor visits
no and then i've noticed that when after
he goes he kind of plays off of it he's
kind of good to go but then they just
keep building up on top of each other
like it gets even more
almost fantastical like now we're at the
point where he has a brain tumor i'm
like oh gosh
number one
nobody's ever used the word fantastical
on this show ever so elaine you get a
special star i may call you out in the
next newsletter for excellent word to
use fantastical i'm writing that down
all right so
this actually sounds so hypochondriac is
like one of those words like narcissist
um or i've got anxiety or i've got adhd
it's just it's a diagnostic that's
thrown around a lot
this actually sounds like what you're
dealing with not just somebody who's got
a low pain tolerance or somebody who
actually has some medical issues that
they're trying to figure out
this sounds like somebody who has made
um
medical fears a part of their identity
so being having a medical diagnostic a
diagnosis is becomes part of a
hypochondriac's um identity like you and
you nailed it he almost it feels like he
wants to be sick he doesn't want to be
sick but like he doesn't want to hurt
and be dying
but there this has become part of his
identity that i go to doctors i google
things and i've got phantom pains and
etc
so
hypochondriac another way to think of it
is a an illness
anxiety disorder is really what it is
and um it does sound like he needs some
psychological care right now and not an
overdramatic way but i do think he needs
to go talk to a counselor about where
this
where this is coming from because here's
the loop you get in
you go to a doctor they do all the tests
and they say i don't know here's some
take some vitamin d i mean they'll make
up something they'll give you something
or try this thing for 12 days and see if
it feels better
and
this is my opinion i don't have any data
to back this up
but i know that anxiety i do have data
to back up anxiety is a connection issue
it is people who are disconnected
i have a strong hypothesis that those
who struggle from hypochondria they get
that connection through doctors through
experts
somebody that will look at them give
them 30 minutes of undivided attention
give them their expertise their opinions
and their bodies go
i'm connected
and then they get home and
they spin up something else and then now
i've got to go find the next so you went
from headaches to
foot pain to any sorts of anything has
there been a lot of covet related stuff
no actually
no no
okay so and then now we're at brain
tumor and cancer is usually the big one
right i've got cancer this is happening
it's all coming down and let's be honest
there is a
minuscule statistical problem i mean
possibility
that he's got brain cancer probably not
we all walk around with that
every day right
so most hypochondriacs the the word i've
i've heard used that i love is they need
a witness
and when we love somebody who is
struggling with this type of challenge
it becomes more as you say fantastical
and it's hard to be a witness to
like hey look i'm writing a unicorn
check it out it's like okay great i need
you to
go outside and finish the yard or
whatever
and we also have to realize that the
mind is so powerful
so incredible the research on placebo is
staggering
and it can create
real pain and real challenges it can it
can manufacture them on its own if you
will
so what i'm telling you this is this is
actually hard this is harder than it
sounds and i do think he needs to go
talk to somebody
and i do think it's probably rooted in
anxiety and again i'm not talking to him
and i do think there's some pc finds
through the connection through medical
providers and it does get really
expensive and it does get really
really hard to be in a relationship with
somebody similar to somebody struggling
with anxiety
what are things you all have tried in
your home
well i've tried everything from
sympathy to
tough love and it all seems to end the
same way as it like exactly like you
said like you don't love me
you know you don't care and then it ends
up with me saying no i do love you
that's why and i'm also a nurse
[Laughter]
no you're not going to bring your
knowledge to this situation are you
right so he'll ask for my opinion and
then he does and
you're right we have half bottles of
pills laying around
and
you know the foot doctor said take these
pills for a month and that was over the
summer and they're still a half bottle
of pills of course
right right so i just and i if i
tell him
straight out like if i take the tough
love approach and say
it it's just
a total nightmare but i also don't want
to give if you give in to the the uh
like oh well maybe maybe you should go
get it checked out
that causes almost like a spiral as well
like he just keeps going with it and
until we end up at a doctor and and you
know i do sense that it is much more
anxiety related
and
um
so if i bring that up to him i have
brought that up to him it's uh
no
you don't believe me exactly yeah and
it's really hard to be in relationship
there because then it's a spiral at that
point you can't win that engagement
there's you're in a place where you
can't fix this
what you can do is love him
you can um the next time you'll go to
some doctor to go with him
and let them know i believe at this
point here is the
here's our trajectory and you hand that
doctor here's the last set of so let me
back up here's um and i've talked about
this i think on this show i know i've
talked about it in some live events
recently
um
really cool i read a book by ethan cross
and i mean i read several books a week
and occasionally one or two things will
stick with me um or i'll add to a body
knowledge this is one that was
extraordinary for me i'd never heard it
i thought it was mumbo jumbo and i've
tried it and it is unbelievable how
successful it's been
so i run pretty hot when it comes to
anxiety and i can i can
i have i have a pretty regimented life
it's a silly fun life but i have a
regimented life so that i don't get to
those places and over the last decade i
mean i'm almost
anxiety free but if i get tired and i
don't eat right and end and then i start
withdrawing and i can find myself spun
up if i let it get that way
so
ethan cross the book's called chatter
and it's about the inner voice and
there's been evidently been a lot of
research on the inner voice in our heads
that just keep going all day every day
all day every day just telling stories
stories story stories stories
and he
dropped some information that i'd never
heard before and here's what he here's
what he said
he said
when our bodies
think and solve for i or we
there is a neural circuit that
the i and we conversation inside our
head operates on and it's the
fight-or-flight circuit
so
i don't know what i need to do i don't
know if i should be buying this thing
should i even be moving to this house
should i marry this person should we
have another kid
that is an immediate threat that your
body tries to solve and it solves it and
you know this as a nurse it solves it
with adrenaline and cortisol and
dopamine all kinds of things with um all
sorts of hormones and neurotransmitters
all this stuff
when we think of them they
our bodies don't take off on us
it doesn't try to solve that it's a
different circuit
and
and i hate using tech
metaphors to describe the human brain
but it it's easy on this one
so
what this guy's recommendation was when
you have hard decisions to make if
you're struggling with addiction if you
are working through really tough
challenges
talk to yourself in the third person
write your journal in the morning in the
third person
because here's what happens
when i'm struggling i teach
relationships in marriage and parenting
for a living and there are times i don't
know what to do with my kids and i'm
just scrolling like in my mind what am i
supposed to do here
then my buddy calls and says hey my son
is filling the blank is doing this this
and this and i can go well yeah just do
that that and that
because my brain's not in fight or
flight my prefrontal cortex is still
connected
and so
if i talk to myself in the third person
often
my brain doesn't react my thinking brain
my rational brain stays intact so what
does this have to do with your situation
number one i want you to keep a front
and present spreadsheet
or a word document
that has all of the ailments and the
dates and what y'all did
okay and i want this to be an ongoing
list that can be seen because anxiety
thrives off chaos
and so we're going to clear this up
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to talk to let's say your
husband's name is tom
we're going to talk to tom in the third
person
because my guess is if your husband had
a buddy show up
and say hey man i
thought i had foot pain and then i
thought i had chest pain and then i
thought i had headache pain and then i
thought of neck issues pretty sure it's
a brain tumor your husband would
probably say i bet you don't just as a
first default response
but when it's your body
your body takes over for you and then
it's in fight or flight and then we're
not thinking straight
and so
when he comes to you with a new ailment
i want you all to write it down and
maybe maybe even put i'm going to be
obnoxious here okay but maybe put a star
wars figure or a lego figure or some
sort of something on the coffee table
and i want you to talk to tom
and say tell tom what your what your um
what your symptoms are what are you
feeling
and what would we tell tom that he
should probably do
and your husband should
be able to have that conversation
without it becoming internalized and the
hope there is you begin to have
more
i don't say rational but more
fact-based
more direct more um yeah more rational
conversations about do i really have a
brain tumor what is the data that would
tell me i have a brain tumor
and begin to go down that rose that
makes sense
and then when you go to the doctor next
time i want you to take this list and
hand it to the doctor
and let the doctor know i am concerned
as a medical professional that this may
be an anxiety disorder than
more so than physiological challenge
and your husband may get upset with you
he may say you don't trust me you don't
believe me
and call that out in front of the doctor
i'm struggling with connecting here and
it may be on me um but we've here's all
the things we've been through and that
sort of clarity for a doctor would be a
gift
and
know this you can't solve this anxiety
disorder with your husband you can't
solve it and it's going to be fu
rust it's trading
frustrating not a word that's
fantastical it's going to be frustrating
um
what you can do is love him
not give in to either side of this thing
not giving to the despair and hitting
outside the head and also
we're gonna put some boundaries on how
many times we go to the doctor
unless we have some real evidence that
suggests you may have some some maladies
and some challenges
but i want us to
talk to tom not to your husband but i
want us to talk to an external third tom
and begin to look at the data it was
feet and then we had about a week of
whatever this medication is and it all
went away
we had headaches and we weren't able to
solve them we had backaches we weren't
able to solve them now our knees hurt
and there's no solving there and now
we're under brain tumors
and hopefully if we're talking to tom we
can keep our brain plugged in
it won't go limbic on us we'll be able
to look at the data and then at that
point we can say
okay maybe it's something a little bit
different
and i hate that for you
the last step you can do is you go see
somebody
and you model counseling you model
living with somebody who's got lots of
medical challenges you can tell your
husband this i don't know how i can help
you because you seem to be moving from
medical challenge to medical challenge
to medical challenge and i want to love
you and i don't know how because every
time we go get the medical challenge
taken care of
there's no findings
and i'm struggling with how to love you
in this situation the hope being that he
joins you
the hope being that you continue to
invite him you continue to say i want to
love you i want to connect better and i
don't know how to do that
one final final thing
hold his hands every single day and look
him in the eye and tell him that you
love him
and i want you to begin practicing skin
to skin contact it can be sexual it can
be non-sexual
begin to lean into let's don't talk i
just want to hold you i just want to
touch your your hands just want to touch
your face when i touch your feet i want
to hold you
and
the anxiety alarms begin to
this one's tough elaine tough tough
tough
if you struggle with anxiety go see
somebody you're worth it